[Music]
we all watched the Disney movie The
Little Mermaid but only a few of us know
what really happened to Ariel in the
original tale and this is not a fairy
tale story for kids make sure you watch
this video until the end to know if the
mermaid lives happily ever after or not
if you love the little mermaid as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you the messed up
origins of the Little Mermaid tears
would Hans Christian Andersen wrote in
1836 in a tale called
The Little Mermaid once again the Little
Mermaid was one of the Kings daughters
and the most beautiful of them but this
time everyone including her sisters was
fascinated by the human world and what
she loved more was a marble statue of a
handsome man
her grandmother told her everything
about the human world
and unlike scuttle she was actually
really wise she told The Little Mermaid
about the day when she was going to turn
15 and have the right to rise up out of
the sea sit on the rocks in the
moonlight and see what is happening on
the land The Little Mermaid who was the
youngest daughter and her family waited
several years for that day her sisters
kept talking about what they saw and the
youngest couldn't wait for the day when
she was going to see it too
at first they were amazed but after
visiting this place too often they
became indifferent and didn't care
anymore
when the moment she had been waiting for
finally came the Little Mermaid rose to
the surface of the sea this is when she
saw a boat came closer to it and noticed
a really handsome prince it was love at
first sight but then a storm came her
man fell in the water and she had to
save him as she lay on the shore she
kissed his forehead and admired the man
he looked just like the marble statue
that she used to love she waited until
someone came to help him and then left
the Little Mermaid couldn't forget this
man and she spent many nights in the
water near his palace to watch the young
prince unlike her sisters she kept
loving this new world more every time
she learned more about him every day and
even heard the fisherman talking about
how great he was The Little Mermaid
wished that she could be part of his
world
however she realized that they were
actually really different in this tale
humans could die while mermaids could
live up to 300 years but humans also had
a soul that lives forever
while sea creatures just cease to exist
when they died this was one of the main
reasons why the Little Mermaid wanted to
become a real woman her grandmother
tried to convince her that mermaids
lived to be much happier and much better
than humans but the young girl didn't
mind she could die for her prince if it
meant being happy as stars in the sky
forever but her grandmother told her
that the only way she could have an
immortal soul was if the man fell in
love with her if they ever got married
his soul would glide in her body and
they would be united this is why while
everyone was at the ball she decided
that she would do anything it would take
to meet her prince her grandmother told
her that a fishtail was
under the seed that looked disgusting on
earth and this is why she had to find a
way to have legs she went to see the
sorceress and even the sea witch said
that she was stupid but there was
something she could do for her the
little mermaid could drink a draught
that would make her tail disappear and
turn into legs that would make her the
prettiest little human being they ever
saw that this transformation will feel
as if a sword was passing through her
and every step she takes would feel like
she was treading upon sharp knives if
she could bear with this the sorceress
would help her and the little mermaid
was so desperate that she said yes the
sea witch had to warn her that once she
became human she will never see the ones
that she loves ever again and only
become foam on the crest of the waves it
wasn't enough to stop the young girl but
then the sorceress said that she had to
pay the prince in exchange for a pair of
legs she had to give away her voice the
mermaid said yes one last time and the
sorceress
cut off her tongue before preparing the
drop the little mermaid didn't even take
the time to say goodbye to those she
loved as she felt too dumb after making
that choice when she rose up through the
dark blue waters to go on the shore and
drink the magic drop she felt like a
two-edged sword went through her
delicate body and fell just like she was
dead as she discovered from the sharp
pain a prince stood beside her he took
her to his palace but every step she
took felt as if treading upon the points
of needles or sharp knives but she
mostly felt dumb as she couldn't speak
when this handsome man tried to talk to
her she was jealous when she heard a
beautiful slave singing her voice was so
beautiful that the prince was only
looking at her but the little mermaid
stole the show when she finally had the
chance to dance with the prince even
though she was suffering during all this
time she spent more and more time with
her lover kissing and cuddling but she
kept smiling while she couldn't stop
thinking about the pain as the day
passed she was more in love with the
prince
but he loved the silent
only as he did love a child and not as
his future wife he even called her his
dumb child the prince needed to find a
beautiful princess to marry but he only
had one on his mind he kept thinking
about the woman who saved his life and
the Little Mermaid couldn't tell him
that it was her the Prince finally met a
woman who was so beautiful that he
thought that she was the one who saved
him and told The Little Mermaid that he
was finally happy
but the young girl was heartbroken and
it hurt more than her legs his wedding
was going to bring her to death she held
up the bride's train and danced all
night no matter how painful that was as
it was the last night that she would
spend with her Prince as she looked at
the scene The Little Mermaid saw her
sister they had heard about this tragedy
and gave their hair to the witch
exchanged for a knife if the young girl
plunged it in the heart of the prince
before the Sun rises she would become a
mermaid again and have the chance to be
with her family again but she couldn't
do it The Little Mermaid threw away the
knife and threw herself into the sea for
her body dissolved into foam but she
didn't die he became one of the
daughters of the heir by her cadiz she
had earned an immortal soul she would be
flying around the world in the air until
after 300 years she should float into
the kingdom of heaven and this is how
the Little Mermaid had the chance to
live her happily ever after and peace
away from pain which berry tells story
do you prefer don't be shy to answer in
the comments section down below we'd
love to hear what you think and that's
it for the nest of origins of the Little
Mermaid for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 disturbing real
stories behind Disney fairy tales thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]